New York Times an article came out about
her saying she's against gay couples
adopting kids okay okay so she's against
gay couples adopting kids that is
something she's not comfortable with if
that's anti-lgbt then that's her
position she's not for gay couples uh
adopting a kid but he's also threatened
basically to do away with same-sex
marriages I don't this is not anything I
really am like obsessed with at all I'm
not gay this is not something that I
believe in but if people want to get
married that's on that exactly 100 judge
you but I'm just letting you know what
she stands for but the the bigger
message here and this kind of will
Circle back to what our friend said in
2011 about being a financial Speculator
is she said it multiple times that I
want people to be an individual not a
number right and uh basically she's
calling out what she calls as us being
consumers or just labeled as consumers
by these massive conglomerates and
basically not being at the whim of
financial speculators so I'm interested
to see what she does with the Italian
economy because I've been to Italy and
like the whole knock on Italy is the the
the northern half of the country
basically supports the whole Southern
behalf of the country the whole Southern
half of the country is basically just on
perennial vacation they don't pay taxes
they're just drinking they're just doing
their legs respect you know plus she's
got an uphill challenge you know Pat can
speak to this all day the mafia still
controls a bunch of stuff in Italy taxes
this kind of stuff so
awesome amazing speech you know Oscar
amazing great gold medal I'd like to see
what actually she does before I anoint
her the queen hear less about what she
does let me let me tell you why I'm
processing this I care less about what
she does since two since they started
their party people know what she stands
for it's not like it's a new thing like
she's been coming up since 2006 when she
hit the political scene so since 2000
for example people are going to know if
let's just say Jedediah runs in 10 years
right yeah let's just say she does I
mean it's a realistic it's a candidate
it's a realistic candidate we're talking
here today it does something 10 years
from now what happened if she does in 10
years people gonna know her stance since
the meeting with Hillary Clinton they're
gonna sit there and say okay this is
what she stood for and they're not gonna
say all of a sudden Jedediah is this to
you and I we've not seen her because
we're not in Italy you're right we're
not part of Italian politics but
for a person a woman to win prime
minister first ever to win this tells
you the fascists that they're talking
about the Republicans they're talking
about they don't care if the prime
minister is a man or a woman but they
care that the values and principles that
that they believe in is protected by a
leader they don't look at her as a woman
I don't look at her as a woman I look at
her as a leader of course she's a mother
she's a Christian she's got all this of
Christians but I look at her as a voice
as a leader and and the only thing you
have to look at is why is this message
resonating today with the Italian people
are they sick of what happened the last
two and a half years that they vote for
somebody to like this salute more power
to the people of Italy quick question
how long do how long is their term for
for those types I didn't tell you did
you know Ty I'm looking okay because I'm
curious like is it like five years is it
ten like how how long was the last prime
minister in there yeah
pull it up what's your question what's
your you just want to do oh I know the
tournament
also I mean I think you're
thinking it resonates
it resonates because
of this there's a void of
will do this it takes a lot of courage
and guts to do this to say these things
it resonates with people in Italy
because all of those backward policies
which by the way we're now trying to
Institute of the United States buried
all the Italian people and they're like
no I'm sorry I want to be able to feed
my family I'm not interested in this
nonsense that's why I resonated with
them it resonated with people in
countries like the United States of
America because we're going the wrong
way and we're trying to say hold on a
second we don't do we really need to be
buried to wake up and the reason I
brought up that point to you Adam was
not to pick on you for saying anti-algia
btq and all that the reason I brought
that up is because it actually really is
an important political point which is
that the left often controls language so
this is a Christian instead of calling
her auntie L LBGTQ why don't you call
her Pro traditional family why don't you
call her she's religious she doesn't
believe in same-sex marriage that's not
a reason to she's not anti she's
pro-something so when we do that
anti-immigrant why because you want to
secure borders so I I just I encourage
people to always just not fall into that
trap now I don't know the specificity
different policy on this that but just
be cautionary about being these labels
that they throw out there you know it's
the same as oh racist bigot anti you
know they throw these labels out when
they want to just have somebody look
like a bigot instead you know she has
her own set of values she has her own
set of things she believes and she's
really they're people religious all over
the United States by the way who don't
believe in same-sex marriage not because
they hate gay people but because they're
religious and that's they're looking at
the Bible they're not bigots so just be
careful with accepting the language of
the left because it's meant to
stigmatize so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]